[Music]
end of watch I got a they sent me a copy
of this film and I watched it incredibly
intense and this is a movie you did with
Jake Gyllenhaal and and I'm just this is
the first movie you've done with with
Jake Jon with Jake and it's written and
directed by David Ayer who wrote
training day yeah you must be I mean
he's got to be an intense director he
did this film he did training day yeah I
know they're running David's like a
badass and you know Jake for this film
like transformed himself into this
badass cop character and where he worked
out he worked out like crazy yeah I mean
he was doing MMA fighting and like just
completely becoming this person and I
was really nervous for my like first day
of rehearsal cuz they're so you know
like stoic tough guys but I when I got
there they were having like this really
intense serious discussion about their
horoscopes that was really um like
compatible star signs and stuff and I
was like okay cool but you guys are like
I mean you're grown men yeah you don't I
really believe that seven they were like
no no no I mean because it's more about
your moon sign so it's like he's
incredibly badass guys but they're like
poring over their horoscopes like a
couple of girls like oh my god you're
having a four star day that's fantastic
you know but then they could get back
into that dark place when they needed to
yeah no I mean the training that that
Jake and everybody went through was so
intense they actually all the cops in
the movies when through all this
training but they got tased like that
was part of it what do they got tazed
for research or whatever like you don't
need to get tased for research that's
what I said I was like I get it Daniel
day-lewis your method but like what you
they were like no you just need to know
like if you were playing a rock climber
who broke their leg would you fall off a
cliff
I would but it wouldn't be intentional
we just happened but I don't understand
that because I was reading I read an
article about this movie and Jake
Gyllenhaal said that there's scenes
where they're using live ammunition you
know like in a training I was like what
do you eat it well just so it can put us
in that zone I don't need to be put in
that know they're boys and they want to
be able to say that they did it yeah but
what but they were tased were you there
when they got no cuz I would have been
like what are you doing like I would
have been the voice of reason and I'd
like to thank were they okay after they
got tased was there hair standing
straight up
I mean even you know the director did it
I was like you know for solidarity I
don't understand it I've never gone
along with any of them I mean they did
like they really did an amazing amount
of work and the performances are so
incredible but that I can't get behind
we have a clip here from end of watch
which I want to reiterate very it's a
terrific movie very intense I cannot say
that word enough it's a it's very well
done a lot of point of view yeah camera
work really like in intense kind of in
in the seat of the action kind of stuff
but the clip you have is this is like
this is a little bit of relief actually
this is when your character in ng no no
no this is your character and then Jake
Gyllenhaal get married and this is the
scene at the wedding is that right yeah
all right let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
not right then